[Music]
[Applause]
you can follow ian rappaport on twitter
at rap sheet and he joins us now ian
before we get to urban meyer i brought
up something in the first hour that i
don't know if the nfl would consider
taking away the final regular season of
uh of games to have everybody have that
opportunity to get ready for the
playoffs is there are there anything is
there anything drastic that's on the
table here
with uh coven
no i mean to me it seems like
what the drastic things are over right
like last week was pretty drastic and it
was
it was a lot of flashbacks from last
year um a lot of
is this game going to be rescheduled
what's it going to mean when are they
going to play this everyone's run short
rest teams are unhappy covert ruining
everything like that felt like
you know that like thursday friday last
week felt like last year and
i had like hard palpitations it was not
fun
um because last year sucked but
based on the way the nfl has adjusted
the cover 19 protocols based on
the threshold now where it's easier for
guys to test out based on the testing
being more symptom-based rather than
just testing every fully vaccinated
asymptomatic person
it seems like these will probably be the
only postponements will have so i i
think the nfl is probably in a pretty
decent spot
i just didn't think it was fair to the
eagles that the washington football team
didn't take care of business and now
you're going to put that on a tuesday
and then you're going to make the eagles
play on saturday yeah
i mean i i i hear you
but do we know that the washington
football team didn't take care of
business like that's that's kind of my
sort of my response i guess you would
say it's like it's covid it seems to be
transmitting
way faster than
anyone imagined and i don't know that
anyone did anything wrong like i haven't
heard that
washington
didn't follow the protocols i mean
remember there
for fully vaccinated players there are
no mass
in buildings it could literally be one
guy going to see his family
or someone's wife or something testing
positive bring it into facility and
that's that like that's
so i don't know they did anything wrong
i don't know that the browns did
anything wrong i think it's just coveted
and covered sucks
when did you get word that urban meyer
wanted to or would allow to uh uh have
you asked him questions
uh so it was actually a little surreal i
have to say so i you know
you always check in you always call it's
always worth it right so when i got the
feeling that
things were going bad
um i got the feeling that
he might get fired
i reached out heard nothing and then i
called on friday morning
just doing my due diligence you never
know maybe he wants to talk so i call
him
nothing no response
um
i text him i said like hey might be a
long shot but i'd love to talk to you if
you want to talk
so he calls me back
and
he says hey you know yeah i'm really
disappointed
um you know it's frustrating i love
jacksonville and i kind of stop and i'm
like
are we can i interview like is this an
interview because he started kind of
started in like it's an interview and
i'm like
can i interview and he was like you know
what what did you have in mind i'm like
getting your feelings on getting fired
it was like all right
and then i i was like can i record you
because i don't want to screw up any of
the quotes he's like that's fine so then
i have an app on my phone which i
haven't used in a while so i had to
download it again while i'm on the phone
with him while he's awkwardly waiting
and i'm like i'm really sorry he's like
it's okay i'm walking on the beach i'm
like all right that's nice so then we
talked for 25 minutes i asked everything
i wanted to ask
um he commented on almost everything
except the legal situation with his
contract
and then
that was it but it was i mean i cannot
honestly say i was expecting to call him
to him to call me back but here we were
why was he fired
he actually summed that up really well
for me so we're kind of going through
things we're talking and he was like you
know there's always a reason someone
answers the phone or someone calls back
right if there's
i'm not you know holding him down and
forcing him to talk to me there's
clearly something he wanted to say so at
some point he said look here's the main
point
we tried really hard and we failed
and i was like yeah that is what it is
because there are plenty of coaches who
treat people not great their player
coaches are yellow players or coaches
who treat who are very hard on their
assistance
right um that's a kind of a technique
where you're really hard on your
assistant so you don't have to be hard
on your players right
um
in the end he wasn't a good enough
football coach because has he had even
better
then
we wouldn't be in this situation all
this stuff would have been just kind of
stuff
but like
he kind of stopped being an ex as a nose
coach several years ago he's more of a
culture builder he's more of a ceo type
coach
i don't think in the end his assistant
coaches didn't do a good enough job he
didn't do a good enough job and then he
got fired
but when you get fired for cause
are you is the cause you're a bad coach
no
um although
i'm not going to anyway um i'm not going
to say what i was going to say um
no he got fired for cause because of
several specific incidents there was the
incident with josh lamba which he has
denied there's the incident with a woman
who was not his wife at a bar
in columbus which you can't deny was on
video um
and then you know there were there are
the other reports and all that but
firing for cause is a
legal
move i guess you would say i don't know
that's not really the right word but to
not pay
so i would imagine they will go into
negotiations now to come up with some
sort of settlement where he will leave
with a certain amount of money that will
probably be less than he was originally
scheduled to get paid
but
if you're wondering about the timing
which i think everyone was wondering
about
to me the best way i could sum it up
was
they knew they were going to fire him it
was obvious he was gone at the end of
the season
so if you're going to do that just fire
him now and then the stories stop
yeah but with lambeau that's in august
is
you know
whatever you want to call it in a bar in
columbus like those are those fireable
offenses and and if it was that bad in
august why not fire him then if this
team has six wins ian
okay is he fired
probably not
probably not because
let's say they had six wins that would
be an improvement and let's say you had
some moments from trevor lawrence where
like he looks like he's kind of getting
in and being the guy you want him to be
probably not fired to me this is like he
wasn't they did not think he was good
enough football coach he didn't win
enough games
and then there was all the other stuff
so it's like let's just do this now we
get the stories to stop fire him for
cause and then you know you almost
always in this situation you settle i
mean even john gruden settled right
um
so with the raiders not with the nfl um
so i think that's kind of the situation
here is just do it now make this bad
story stop
and start the process of replacing them
get the feeling urban
wants to coach again
ah
i didn't get that feeling
he said to me
that
you know he was kind of going through
and i could sort of see his mind
churning a little bit he was like you
know i had the perfect life
before this and then shod recruited me
and he meant so much to me and he really
did up the perfect life i mean you know
not all tv jobs are are the same
um some of us have to work every day as
you know um but he didn't he only worked
on saturdays and he was on fox and so
like would i be surprised if he was back
on fox talking about college football
like i wouldn't be surprised
um
what is going to be interesting is you
know there are a lot of great college
football jobs filled this year but like
let's say next year one of those really
good jobs comes open
i don't know if he's going to be tempted
because i don't think he ended up i
didn't think he thought he was going to
be tempted by the jaguars but he was
yeah i i
i don't know and i talked to somebody at
fox over the weekend and they're like
hey you know we would welcome him back
yeah i heard that too yeah i'm just
curious if uh
like it's hard to go out this way it's
like a player doesn't want to go out you
know losing
you know does he want to go out with his
reputation or legacy with this attached
to it and that's what i always wonder if
if he's and he's not old what is he 57
he's just been do he's just been a great
coach for so long
you know so it's like i'm a mets fan i
hired buck showalter and i'm like wow he
must be like 80 but he's but he's not
yeah he just has done it he was
he was an older looking coach for
yankees and he's like 35. um
so i i don't know the answer to that
question i know this didn't leave a
great taste in his mouth and i was
surprised at how much he talked about
just
failing like he was it was very matter
of fact you know sometimes
you sort of feel like during interviews
and i'm sure you've been through this
you feel like you sort of have to dance
around some things like this wasn't that
at all he was real upfront with getting
fired and not doing a good enough job
you know
yeah i i wondered about that but you
know what can you say and how how
usually you're going to know early on in
an interview and you're like oh okay you
know we we can go there or
i i feel like i got the green light here
a little bit and and maybe he just
wanted to explain and get it off you
know he wanted people to hear his side
and i wonder about the josh lambeau
story though ian because i don't know if
that's one of those where
you know you you kick him but you're not
really you're just hey come on can i
make go out there make some damn kicks
or whatever i i don't did he explain his
side of that you know did he kick the
kicker
um he
he denied it
um
you know the more i
the more i delve into the situation and
i think what he denied was the specific
way that josh lambeau illustrated it in
uh
in the tampa newspaper template times
right in the tampa bay times you know
i have no doubt that he came over and
called him something especially because
i think at that point and this is like
i still honestly think he's trying to
learn who everybody was so like did he
have a nickname for the kicker like
probably you know that's just the way
he's always been so like did he come
over
tap him on the butt with his shoe and
say like come on whatever like make some
kicks
probably did probably trying to build a
little rapport clearly did not work
clearly lambo was you know
didn't was not feeling it you know and i
think maybe not everybody likes to be
called names like that
but
i'm just
this is not
i'm not exp i'm not explaining it away
this is not that i'm just saying
logistically if you kick a player
and it's during stretching and there's
media there and there's fans there and
everyone is watching and other players i
just imagine there'll be some larger
reaction than everyone finding out a
couple months later talking to ian
ravenport and a national insider for the
nfl network any further updates on
deshaun watson
no um he is he is lanquishing uh on the
active roster he is an active um
the next legal checkpoint i believe is
depositions which should be in
february or march unless the cases
get settled and you know he was not
traded to the dolphins because he was
not able to settle his
uh 20 plus cases
in the offseason you know i would
imagine he gets traded i don't know the
timing of it but there's going to be
more the whole offseason's going to be
around quarterbacks like last offseason
was
this is going to be the off season i
think we were supposed to have because
we could have several big time guys on
the move i think he does get on the move
and a lot i mean so many teams so many
teams need quarterbacks in a draft where
you're going to get some but you're not
going to get all the answers is baker
mayfield playing tonight
he is not no uh i think baker mayfield
thought he was going to play he posted
on the old instagram that he thought he
was going to play
a couple minutes ago i think actually
right before we started
they announced their final transactions
before the game
um john johnson the safety comes off the
list so he's playing but baker no case
keenum no
so uh a lot of nick mullins who the last
time we saw him on a national stage was
balling out
um
we'll see if he can resurrect his career
today look at you selling it
great hey it is exclusive on nfl network
now is that the reason i'm selling nick
bones no it's like a coincidence i'm
just saying it's okay yeah of course it
is and it's uh exclusively on the nfl
network yeah at five eastern tune uh
great job ian thank you appreciate your
time all right thanks dan thanks for
watching that's ian rappaport national
insider for the nfl network at nfl.com